oh my so I'm gonna start off my first
new view on my new channel by saying
thank you thank you for sticking with me
yet again I will do my best
vanishing on 7th Street sounds like the
title of a goosebumps book so vanishing
on 7th Street stars Hayden Christensen
yeah him sandy Newton John Leguizamo and
a little kid whose name I don't know
it's directed by Brad Anderson the
director of The Machinist
you know the movie where Christian Bale
was like a skinny as a toothpick it
starts off very much like an x-files
episode it starts off with these three
main characters and then all of a sudden
literally everyone around them just
disappears clothes everywhere you know
there's shoes all the things people were
carrying are on the floor exactly where
they were when they disappeared but
their bodies are gone I thought the
first 15 minutes of this movie were
perfect the first 15 minutes or so of
the movie is just the characters
discovering this world now where
everyone's gone and it is so area and so
suspenseful to see all these shots of
the city without anyone there kind of
like an I am Legend with Will Smith and
then the film takes a turn that I think
is a fatal flaw for the film let me
start off by saying I actually really
enjoyed this movie but there's one thing
they did in this film that I thought
actually really took away from the film
a lot and if they just had them done
this one little thing it would have been
so much better as soon as all the
characters discover this new world and
then they're all of a sudden they're
like crap what are we gonna do it cuts
two three days later and then it shows
all these same characters and they're
already experienced in dealing with this
this world of their living and they've
already figured out that light protects
them and that the shadows are trying to
kill them losing that three day period
of watching all the characters having to
learn all that for themselves I thought
the film lost a lot of potential really
awesome scene because of that the feel
of the film up to that point was like
crap how are they gonna you know deal
with this then it just cuts the three
days later and they all know what
they're doing kind of believe it or not
Haim Christmas
actually wasn't that bad in this movie
and I can't really think of one John
Leguizamo performance where I've been
like you know what I love John Leguizamo
John Leguizamo's a good actor I've never
been impressed with him once in fact
whenever I see that he's in a movie I'm
kinda like oh yeah this film is really
actually very creepy the shadows as a
villain actually kind of unnerved me a
little bit there was a lot of really
good direction where like in the
background of a shot you just sort of
see maybe like a shadow that looked like
it was just like a normal shadow of
something just sort of start to move and
like oh crap that thing's alive it's
very well directed but the direction is
definitely better than the script if
they hadn't have done that three days
later thing it would have been really
nice to see how the characters
discovered what they had to do to
survive in this world this is a fun
movie though I mean it's like Twilight
Saga the x-files and I like both of
those things the score is very good and
very creepy good direction that's a
great script story we've seen before you
know I am Legend The Happening kind of
thing you know with the world's falling
apart and these people have to kind of
deal with it the movies gonna be opening
and limited release February 11th
however currently it's available online
on demand and on TV on demand
I'll definitely suggest renting it
online or on TV because I don't know if
this is like a theater movie it's
definitely a fun Saturday night curl up
and watch it with popcorn or whatever
movie but I wouldn't spend that much
more I'm going to give vanishing on 7th
Street three out of four stars it's a
fun tense little Twilight Zone kind of
movie but it's nothing remarkable stay
tuned on the monday cuz i'm getting a
special screening of the mechanic with
jason statham